so you guys know South Park came out in
about 1995 or 1996 I was still a
Simpsons guy and I believe that you
could only watch one thing you had to be
a Simpsons guy or a South Park guy so I
just never got on the South Park train
but my team of young people here keep
telling me that I've missed something
with South Parks they want me to watch a
couple South Park clips and see what
happens here we go listen listen
everyone nobody can leave this building
but we need supplies Foods silicone you
go outside and you'll die by now the
global warming has shifted the climate
bringing on a new Ice Age within the
hour the temperature outside will fall
to over 70 million de below
zero Jesus all we can do is try to wait
it out as long as we can and the rest of
the
country everyone below this line will
have to be evacuated to the South
everyone above this line is already dead
People Like Us in the middle states have
to ride it out the baly southwestern
States might have a chance but New York
will have tidal waves that envelop all
of the
Northeast what
Frank oh oh God damn
it some quality comedy right there all
right I think we got a couple more here
we are really trying to understand this
how is it that you boys think referring
to gay people as Fs in today's world is
acceptable because we're not referring
to gay people you can be gay and not be
a yeah a lot of aren't gay I happen
to be gay boys do you think I'm
a do you write a big loud Harley and go
up and down the streets ruining
everyone's nice time no then you're not
a what if a guy is is gay and rides a
Harley then he's a gay I mean is this
really this hard I don't
know all right look you're driving in
your car okay and you're waiting to make
a left at a traffic signal the light
turns yellow should be your turn to go
but the traffic coming at you just keeps
coming and even when the light turns red
a guy in a BMW runs the red light so you
can't make your left turn what goes
through your
mind right but you're not thinking oh
he's a homosexual you're thinking oh
he's an inconsiderate douchebag like a
Rider this this is making insanely good
sense to
[Laughter]
me ah City Council meetings you know if
they were only that simple all right
what do we got and now back to Wheel of
Fortune all right Randy congratulations
on making it all the way to the bonus
round thanks Pat you've got some family
here watching tonight yeah they're all
rooting for me and I'm sure you have
lots of of friends watching back home
yeah hi everybody watching in South Park
that's
us us hey good luck well let's see if
you can't make everyone proud the
category is people who annoy you okay as
always we give you the letters r t s l
and
E we just need three more consonants and
a vowel okay I'd like a
b an n and a g and the vowel and and oh
please okay well looks like you're going
to get a lot of help here category is
people who annoy you audience keep
please uh well uh 10 seconds Mr Marsh I
know it but I don't think I should say
it 5 Seconds Mr Marsh all right I'd like
to solve the
puzzle
huh that's good that's good everybody
hates him of course naggers right uh can
we cut to uh can we cut to
a all right that's good that's good
comedy that's good comedy all right what
do we
got hey guys can I help you hello there
are certain networks that we see as
harmful to our families and we want them
removed please oh you don't want cable
anymore no no just ID network A&E oxygen
and Oprah network all the ones with
murder porn you don't like paying for
all the channels oh our company actually
packages channels
together well can you unpackage them so
we only get the channels we want oh I'm
sorry our company doesn't work that way
you want me to give you the number of a
different cable company that can oh wait
we're it aren't
we dang it guess you have to deal with
our
packages can we talk to your supervisor
please what oh sure hey David hi is
there a problem
here we want specific networks dropped
from our cable oh you have to pay for
the bundle you can't just pay for what
you want to watch darn it you mean that
we're forced to pay for the Oprah
Channel I guess if you don't want to be
forced to pay for Oprah you'd have to
shut off your cable altogether fine then
we'll shut our cable off Al together hey
Mitch when can you get out to shut off
some cable boxes oh man it's going to be
like 3 weeks there's a whole plug I have
to pull out it's like 4 in Long 3 weeks
huh okay is 3 weeks from now okay with
you guys no that's way too long oh it is
oh jeez that's
terrible God damn it I just don't want
my parents to murder each
other can't you see that all we're
trying to do is keep our family safe
look I don't know seen couples murder
each other on television is going to
make my parents do it and we probably
won't be able to stop them from watching
what they want to watch all we're trying
to do is make it a little more difficult
for them because cable makes it so
convenient sure if they didn't have easy
access to their murder porn channels
they'd be bummed out but it's not just
our responsibility to give them what
they want is
[Music]
it say say that last part again what
what was the last part you said I said
it's not our responsibility to give them
what they want no no the part about your
parents not getting the channels easily
I said it would really bum them out how
how much would it bum them
out maybe I missed something with the
younger people and the nipple thing but
the bundling and unbundling is
interesting to me cable it's why we did
locals you subscribe to the things you
like but something something I'm not
going to rub my nipples right now is
that it all right we got one more from
the South Park television
program you guys we have got problems of
biblical proportions where have you been
I've been counting do you know there are
205 Mexicans here and there are 190
black people so what so guess how many
white people are at the water park
today 143 there are actually more
minorities here than us well then
they're not minorities are
they what do you mean dumbass if there's
60% of them to 40% of us then who's the
minority the black and brown people
you're the minority do I look like a
minority to you
stupid it's
true the obvious end of social justice
white people will be the minority thus
the
oppressed Planet of the
Apes